[موسيقى]
من المعروف انه الصيام وخصوصا لفترات
تتجاوز 16 ساعه تقريبا يؤدي الى انخفاض ما
يسمى بالكوليسترول الضار اولسترول
وان هذا وانه هذا الامر ينعكس ايضا على
بشكل جيد وهذا ومهمه اللي هو ازاله
الكوليسترول من الجدران الشرايين ومعروف
خطر الكوليسترول
ارتفاع بتشكل ما يسمى بالعصيده الشريانيه
التي تترسب على جدران اوعيه الدمويه بماده
لحدوث الجلطات القلبيه او الدماغيه طبعا
رمضان فرصه مهمه جدا لتخفيض هذا النسبه
هذا المستوى العالمي الكوليسترول
اولا يجب ان يلتزم المريض الذي يستخدم
الادويه في رمضان باستعمال هذه الادويه
واكمالها في شهر الصيام لان هذه الادويه
لا تختلط التعديل كما يحدث عند استعمال
ادويه السكر مثلا الامر الثاني يجب على
المصابين ايضا
باكثار من السوائل في رمضان لان كثره
السوائل تؤدي الى عدم تشكل او تنقص من
نسبه احتماليه حدوث خثرات واعيه او مجلطات
دمويه من الامور الاخرى المهمه ايضا موضوع
المشي او الرياضه في رمضان واقلها المشي
تقريبا لمده 30 دقيقه خمس مرات بالاسبوع
او ما يتعدى 150 دقيقه افضل اوقات المشي
هي قبل الافطار مباشره او بعد الافطار
بساعتين من الامور الاخرى المهمه ايضا
الحرص على تناول كميات جيده من
الاطعمه من الحاويه على الكربوهيد رات غير
المشبعه او الزيوت غير المشبعه غير مشروع
لانها تساعد في خفض نسبه الكوليسترول
كموضوع زيت الافوكادو او السمك او سمك
السلمون او زيت الزيتون او الجوز واللوز
[موسيقى]